six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go to
our next caller from the six one seven
area code and if you're holding please
don't hang up we are going to make an
effort to get to folks six one seven
you're up next
am I on the line you are but it sounds
like we might either be on speakerphone
or on some kind of headset is that is
that the case
oh I'm using you know if you wouldn't
mind I think it would it would help
everybody out yeah it looks better it's
slightly better now it sounds like
speaker but let's let's work with it
okay um my name is Terri ah
I'm from Newton so I just was calling
today on during my lunch break and all
that um I just wanted to talk to you
about the segment you did yesterday
about um AOC and basically um I I
thought it was pretty interesting and
all that you like I agree so let's see
just to make sure probably know what
you're talking about
AOC you mean Alexandria Acacio Cortes
and we did a segment earlier in the week
where she was asked about her position
on the israeli-palestinian conflict yep
that's big that's the segment I'm
referring to yep okay I thought it was
pretty interesting I know you it was
pretty interesting and I agree with you
that you know I think she was somewhat
pretty vague about um the like some of
her positions and she definitely should
have I think she'd have done more
research and to kind of understand it
more although I think compared to what's
being said in like Congress and with
other but like other top elected
officials I thought you did a pretty
decent job compared to them what I want
to understand what you what you mean by
that Terry so what did she hold on a sec
what did she say that you liked better
or found more informed than like other
things that you've heard well I don't
really hear much from like politicians
which actively talked about like what's
going on in Palestine on days except for
like Bernie Sanders and maybe a couple
of other politicians who tend to be like
more aligned with J Street so I don't
usually tend to hear that and I'm not
here to say like you know aoc did like a
spectacular job or anything but I like
how he
about how it's important to arm I was
important to basically speak against the
occupation and to try to figure and try
to find ways to help improve the
livelihood of ordinary Palestinians
while at the same time acknowledging
Israel's right to exist and arguing that
there has to be a two-state solution so
that's generally what I liked and all
that do and then that's going off of
that so I felt I don't know I felt like
you kind of were rushed for time cuz he
ain't yet like I think the whole thing
on that on her comments were about three
minutes and I think he heard about like
a minute and a half so I kind of fell
was a bit rushed for time I'm not here
to say that you know I'm not even
playing you for that I'm obviously I
don't know I like I guess you know
probably were out for time or something
cuz I know in the end of the clip you
said you were like out of time for today
or something for yeah
I do think right you know maybe he might
have been better yet the idea maybe like
two or three extra minutes to kind of
play the whole response in full and then
that way I think there'd have made more
people in the same space because when I
already saw your clip I kind of was like
I was thinking the worst that happened
it wasn't until I saw David stole from
the rational Nashville when he did his
clip not it kind of understood the full
context of what what a okie I said now
this is say I don't think a leader like
a track like a terrific job where I
think I think he I don't think he did
this family if he said she did alright
fair enough so you so you're not you're
not saying you think she's particularly
well-informed but you don't think she
did as badly as I felt she did yeah
basically all right very good okay Terry
thank you for uh thank you for the
feedback appreciate hearing about that
let's take a quick break if you're on
hold don't hang up because we will take
more calls right after the break